okay you heard it here first minotaurs
are people see you next time on every
damn day cup oh man I still don't think
they should be able get married wow dude
man sir great show guys love the energy
today but bad news Ryan is coming back
from his vacation today
yes sir watch out because he is going to
want to talk about it last time you left
town he cornered me for like ten minutes
and I ended up missing my hot yogurt
class you mean yoga oh you misheard me
I said yogurt the thing that I hate
about Ryan is his face and what he says
[Music]
I'm bad I've got photos
oh you buddy you pooping I gotta tell
you about the bathrooms at Six Flags
whoo what'd I do
hey check out this caricature of me what
am i George Bush oh who wants to hear
about my vacation
I've got waterpark photos to show you
Oh Natasha yeah you got to see this I
got a great one this joke
Jourdain I forgot I'm allergic to
mud did you know you can get a speeding
ticket on a jetski no no no I had a
great vacation you ever been on the
paddle boat they're a lot of fun enough
is enough I'm gonna show you these
photos whether you like it or not over
my dead body that can be arranged
[Music]
you're nothing without your pictures
bitch have insurance on this you started
it
I finished it fairly plan hey Hannah
ever heard of the clouds
[Laughter]
you